this.
I want to go to CNN's Kara
Scannell.
She is live outside that
courthouse in Miami that Evan
was referencing there.
Kara, what does it look like
right now?
Did it seem quiet before the
former president posted on truth
social that he has in fact been
told that he has been indicted
here?
>> Yeah, kaitlan, it is very
quiet here.
It is only really a handful of
media that were still in place
when trump made that posting.
I mean, all day it was pretty
quiet.
Well did see some of the key
prosecutors who were on the
special counsel's team working
on the documents case, and we
saw one of them going out to get
lunch.
We saw them going back into the
cafeteria to get some snacks,
some chips and cookies.
And then we also had heard at
the end of the day, after
everyone had gone that there
were a bunch of pizza boxes back
in the grand jury room.
But we weren't sure if the grand
jury had met or even that they
had voted.
But it has been a relatively
tranquil scene here today.
Of course, if you remember back
in New York after trump was
indicted on the state charges by
the Manhattan district
attorney's office, it was a
similar thing.
The indictment came down on a
Thursday.
He was arraigned the following
Tuesday.
That gave everyone time to get
into place.
So you can imagine the scene
here will become quite busy, not
only the media descending, but
also potentially some trump
supporter, some members of the
public.
As Evan was just explaining,
they will have to get a security
programmer in place here.
Trump being at mar-a-lago, as
you well know, they're used to
having him, transporting him
around.
But this is certainly of a
different magnitude and
dimension, the first time a
former president facing federal
charges.
There was this run-through in
New York.
We saw how that worked.
What's unclear here is how they
will handle it internally.
Will they shut down the
courthouse like they did in new
York, freezing the building,
freezing the floors that the
former president was going to be
on, and then creating a pretty
rigorous system of who would be
able to get into the courtroom
to witness this because there
are no cameras in court.
And there are no cameras in
federal court.
So the public won't get a
glimpse of this.
It remains to be seen how
they're going figure out the
logistics of having this
arraignment take place on
Tuesday.
Kaitlan?
>> Remarkable to see a second
indictment in just such a short
period of time.
Thank you, Kara.
>>> More perspective now.
Joining me now is our senior
political correspondent Abby
Phillip, Paula Reid, chief
national correspondent John
king, and conservative lawyer
and "Washington post"
contributing columnist John
Conway, who has long predicted
that this moment would come to
pass.
But it's historic.
>> It is absolutely.
>> No other president has faced
federal charges before.
>> It is absolutely historic.
This is probably the most
significant historically -- most
historicalcally important
criminal case since the Aaron
burr case at the beginning of
the 19th century when he was
tried for treason.
It is stunning to see.
It's breath taking to see, but
it's not surprising at all.
The fact of the matter, and
Donald Trump is going to argue
that he was mistreated, and he
is being singled out and he is
being abuse.
But the fact of the matter is
he's gotten the Ben of the
doubt.
If you or any of us at this
table had been a government
official in the white house
during the trump administration
and we took this volume of
documents home and we jerked
around the national archives and
records administration for a
year and a half plus, and then
forced the government to get to
a search warrant, it wouldn't
have taken a year and a half for
them to get the search warrant.
The FBI would have been at our
doors within months.
And the fact of the matter is
when this search warrant came
out, we saw the affidavit.
We saw a redacted affidavit that
the FBI used to get the search
warrant executed at mar-a-lago.
And the amount of information in
there was absolutely stunning at
the time.
I mean, it was shocking at the
time.
That they had such a powerful
case already.
Simply by virtue of the fact
they found the stolen property
in his office and at his home.
So the fact of the matter is he
could have been indicted months
ago.
And again, if it was one of us,
he would have been indicted
months ago.
He has gotten special treatment
in his favor.
And that is not a criticism of
the justice department.
It's a statement of fact that
the justice department has to be
extra careful and extra cautious
and make sure that it has all
its ducks in a row before
bringing a charge against the
former president, a presidential
candidate.
But these charges could have
been brought long ago.
And one other point.
On the venue, there has been the
suggestions that somehow this
was a sudden change in venue.
The fact of the matter is we
knew back in August that there
was going to be a potential
venue issue, and people were
discussing it, legalers were
discussing it, not in the cafes,
not in the coffee shops of
America.
But there was legals.
Because so much of the illegal
conduct that was described in
the FBI affidavit took place at
mar-a-lago, in palm beach,
Florida.
And the constitution, the sixth
amendment provides that a
criminal defendant, here Donald
Trump, the criminal defendant,
is entitled to a jury in the
district and the state in which
he committed the crime.
>> You mention the justice
department.
We haven't heard anything from
them yet, Paula.
Do you expect that we will?
How does the special counsel's
office handle this?
>> Yeah, our reporting right
now, kaitlan is we will not hear
anything from special counsel
jack Smith or his office.
That is a deliberate choice.
They must have known when they
offered the courtesy of
informing he had been indicted,
that's standard, that's what you
would do with most defendants
you knew this was very likely to
wind up on social media, which
is exactly what happened.
They're not going to offer any
statements, any additional
details or unseal the indictment
tonight that is her choice.
But we have to look at how this
worked out with past special
counsels in terms of letting
other people craft the
narrative.
The justice department and FBI
have been under siege.
Criticism about political bias
from both sides of the aisle for
the past seven or eight years,
since the investigation into
Hillary Clinton's use of a
private email server.
One of the reasons we have a
special counsel is because the
attorney general is trying to
protect the integrity, right,
the public's view of the justice
department.
So tonight the fact that the
special counsel is not going say
anything, that we're getting
most of the breaking news from
the former president who has
just been indicted, that is
something that history will
ultimately judge.
It's unclear, though, if this is
the correct decision.
>> Although I think we can
probably say regardless of what
they said something or not,
accusations of bias would always
be there.
Because this was the plan all
along.
Trump and his allies have been
trying to sow the seeds of doubt
about whether this case was
significant or not.
And notably, even the people who
are running against him are sort
of accepting this narrative that
because he is a former
president, and because he is
running for president again,
that that ought to subject him
to some other kind of standard.
And that I think is what will be
tested here once we know the
details of it.
The significance of the
reporting that you and the rest
of the team reported about that
tape in which he is talking
about a specific document, we
don't know whether that document
is involved in this.
We don't know whether that was
all.
Even if it were alone, I think
it really opens the door to a
really serious set of issues
about national security, about
trump trying to utilize the
documents in a way, in any kind
of way, frankly.
Not just to peruse them, but to
prove a point about general mark
Milley.
Those are really serious issues.
And the ones that cannot really
be spun once we know the
details.
>> That's national defense
information.
>> We have not heard one word
publicly from the special
counsel since he took this job.
Which if you're talking about
the grafify of the case,
investigating a former
president, the gravity of the
issues, the you can understand
that.
But if you study the lessons of
the Mueller report, if you study
the lessons of two impeachments,
you also understand what Donald
Trump is going to do and has
been doing.
What he has been doing for weeks
and weeks before this moment and
he has put it on steroids
tonight.
He is telling his people don't
listen to this man.
The deep state is corrupt.
They're after me again.
Don't listen to them.
Smart is cynical, but smart.
If you read the Mueller report,
it id prove collusion?
No.
Did it say a lot of bad things
about Donald Trump?
Yes.
He poisoned the well beforehand
and said do not listen to
anything these people say.
I'm not a lawyer.
Jack Smith's biggest job is
going to be to prove his case in
court.
We're in never never land.
We have never had a candidate of
the United States who is an
active candidate indicted on
federal charges that are
incredibly serious.
This is is not shoplifting.
This is not stealing a car,
running a bad business.
This is taking the most top
secret secrets when he
begrudgingly left the white
house, mad that heed that to
leave, after he tried to fight
so he wouldn't have to leave.
So the biggest challenges in
court, but the first words jack
and his team do say, first on
paper when we see it, and if
they speak to this publicly are
going to be critical to
determine whether Donald Trump's
argument gets out of his base.
If that's the only argument, he
may win the Republican
nomination off it.
But he is a former president,
because the rest of America
stopped listening to him.
We'll see what happens.
>> Within an hour he was already
fundraising off of this.
Maggie, I understand you're
learning new details about these
charges.
We know there are about seven.
What are you learning?
>> Kaitlan, we've been told
there are seven counts, that
none of the counts is the same.
One is a willful retention of
the of the documents, one is to
obstruct involves more than one
person.
And another is false statements.
There are others that we're not
aware of.
A lot so going to matter when
this indictment is unsealed,
when we goat to look at it, when
we got see the criminal
complaint, we will know much
more.
But this tracks can everything
that you and I both know about
this investigation over the last
however many months it's been,
more than a year.
>> Yeah, it has been over a
year.
But when it comes to these
counts, even though the former
president was bracing for this,
he is in New Jersey right now.
He is going to have to go to
Miami, as he's said himself on
truth social on Tuesday for
this.
What's your reporting on how his
mind-set is?
I know he has been making a lot
of phone calls to Republicans,
asking them to attack jack
Smith, to be out there defending
him more voice vociferously.
>> Defying.
He and his team have been
preparing for this for a while.
He has been telling people for
many days he expected to get
indicted, and frankly, he
thought it happened long before
this meeting his lawyers had
with the doj on Monday.
But kaitlan, as you and I both
know, sometimes he reacts a
certain way initially.
And then as the event sinks in
or the facts sinks in, his
behavior changes.
So I'm not quite sure what this
is going to look like.
We know he has two political
events planned for Saturday.
Those are going to be pretty
significant to watch, and
obviously whatever happens in